[Music]
what about resumes i'm asked a lot of
times about resumes
and i
probably pay less attention to resumes
than than most people do
you got to have one
maybe
i mean frankly today
your linkedin profile may be good enough
for most of the things that
that you've got to do if you don't have
a linkedin pro profile you got to get
one and do that do that quick make sure
it's always current and make sure it's
always accurate
beyond a resume
this is a document that helps you tell
your story
and it'll help you if you have a good
story to tell and if you tell it right
so what makes a good story
well in my opinion
good choices
because you're going to have to be
explaining them with logical
explanations because in your career
you're going to be faced with a number
of times where you're going to be
sitting down across the table from
somebody
that you want to convince they ought to
do something positive for you and
they're probably going to look at your
background and look at your resume and
start asking you questions like well why
did you do that
why did you make that choice
why did you go here instead of there
why didn't you stay and get promoted in
this job if in fact you were doing as
good as you tell me
you you were
companying people over product and
compensation i generally advise people
to go work for the best people they can
work for
and for the best companies they can work
for
if the product's not right
and it's a good company and you're
working for great people that'll get
fixed over time
if the if it's the greatest product in
the world and you're working for lousy
people they'll find a way to mess it up
and you'll be on the outs
venture capitalists understand this all
too well i mean one of the oldest
sayings in the venture capital world
is
a an a management team with a b product
will find a way to make their investors
money
and a b management team with an a
product will find a way to mess it up
i mean and that's how they invest you
look at their record and you'll see it
it's people
measurable accomplishments and
promotions
if if you can focus on anything when
you're putting your story together
focus on
what you have accomplished that you can
legitimately take credit for or at least
partial credit for
and be clear which is which when you're
explaining it that's measurable with
facts and figures and things that people
will recognize
and ideally which got you promoted
credible transitions and moves as i said
you're going to be explaining your moves
over time to people who are not going to
take or fluffy
answers and pay much attention to them
so
think
about that before you make a transition
or a move and certainly as you're making
it how you're going to be explaining it
10 15 20 years down the road and when i
scan resumes and i talk to people about
their background the first thing
and the last thing and almost everything
in between that i looked at was where
and when did this person get promoted
because you get promoted
when the people or the company that you
work for thought you did a good enough
job and what the job they gave you to
give you a bigger one
and you know it's it's amazing when i
looked at careers
would see backgrounds
of somebody that starts out
probably not a stanford mba but they
start out as a
you know district sales manager of
company a and then a
a regional sales leader of company b
and then a sales and marketing director
of company c and a vp of sales and
marketing company e and the chief
operating officer of company f
looks like a great progression of titles
they never got promoted never once
so it makes you wonder were they just
getting out of town just before the axe
fell on them and getting lucky to use
their background to get promoted to
another company that would buy
by their uh story and give them a bigger
job and you look around you'll see
people like this all the time and
they're not the people you want to go
work for for one thing
they're going to be
splitting they're not going to take care
of you because they're only concerned
about themselves
and you don't want to be one of those
people so think about
if
if you're close
if you've got an opportunity or you're
thinking about leaving and you're close
to finishing a project you can take
credit for
and getting a promotion
i would urge you think long and hard
before you leave anywhere just short of
a promotion because somebody like me is
going to ask you
why did you leave just short of when you
should have probably gotten promoted
were you going to get promoted
and finally
what makes a good story when you're
telling it to somebody is at the end of
the day at the end of the conversation
you've got to be able to convince them
that you can be successful doing
something that in fact they want done
because if you can convince them that
you can do it but it isn't anything that
they need to have done then you don't go
anywhere or if they have something that
they need to have done and you can't
convince them that you can do it it
doesn't go on anywhere it's only when
you put those two things together
that telling your story
to somebody that matters and can do
something positive with it will get you
a good outcome
how to tell it well we've touched on
some of this
clear clarity of goals and
accomplishments i'm basically an
advocate of a simple chronological
resume that says what you did when you
did it who you did it for what the
results were and and what happened to
you as a result
i mean if you think about those things
that's that's what i'm always looking
for i don't like a lot of fluffy
explanations
uh of of things that don't matter facts
are good if they're true
promotions are better
accurate facts and dates
easy to pick out successes keep in mind
that you you want somebody who's looking
at your resume
or looking at your linkedin profile to
look at something on there and say aha i
can use that that that fits here that's
interesting
logical transitions
no misrepresentations or vague claims
and a clear incredible path to what you
seek
[Music]
you